well your social betters have a habit of
moral posturing we're good people don't
tell you unlike you you've never really
believed it now you know it's totally
fake the China NBA story proves it and
by the way the Ukraine impeachment saga
also does everyone in Washington is
telling you wow it's unbelievable that
Donald Trump would have used a
conversation with a foreign leader to
help politically that never happens
we're not endorsing it but we would like
to give you some context so last night
we showed you a phone transcript where
Bill Clinton who was the president asked
Tony Blair who was the Prime Minister of
Great Britain for a political boost
before the 2000 election weren't
singling out Bill Clinton this is very
very common
now John Kerry has been talking to
anyone who will listen about the
president's shocking behavior with
Ukraine watch my reaction is one of
absolute shock and amazement that is a
fundamental profound abuse of power
there's no other way to put it
fundamental profound no other way to put
it
please shame carries full of it
you knew that but just to put some meat
on those bones during the 2004 election
, which he lost , John Kerry openly
bragged about soliciting support from
foreign leaders against his opponent
that year the incumbent president george
w bush quote I've met foreign leaders
who can't go out and say this publicly
but boy they look at you and say you've
got to win this you've got to beat this
guy
we need a new policy because people love
John Kerry now he was asked which
leaders told you that John Kerry what
did you save them when they said that
and what new policies did you promise
and how did they pledge to help you John
Kerry said he wasn't going to be
specific because it was his right to
keep his conversations with foreign
leaders confidential that's absolutely
necessary for leadership